Douglas what was your acting career like
before the 98th Spirit Award nomination
for Carlos and star maps and then what
was it like afterwards here I mean
you're nominated you know you're going
you've got your red carpet look ready
you're like okay most people would do
anything to be in this position it
happens I think that I was so naive as
to what you needed to do you know like I
said I just sort of went into this
wanting to act it was something that I
enjoyed doing being a celebrity wasn't
always in the forefront it was just
about I don't know playing pretend I
guess and then you get paid which is
really nice so before the Spirit Awards
actually before star maps I was just
sort of working it was like these are
the things that you needed to do get an
agent get a manager and get auditions
then get the job and sort of that was
the process then star maps went to
Sundance and it was all very shocking
you were just like wow this is so big
what's happening all the interviews and
and people coming up to you and
recognizing you and so there was a big
change and there was also a shift
because now it was sort of this
celebrity world that is different from
the actual working world as an actor and
I think that you had to have a different
skin for that because they're not the
same what you do is in actors you know
you sort of are now pretending to be a
character and then what you're doing is
a celebrity is that's who you are in the
life that's like Douglas Spain it's not
Douglas pain as Carlos it's douglas
famous that was spain so that was a bit
shocking because I I always just wanted
to play the character and do what was
best for the story that I was trying to
convey along with everybody else
involved now it was like okay you need a
publicist you need to know how to dress
how to look how you know all this stuff
that had nothing to do with the actual
work it was just part of the show
business you had to you know in order to
get more work you had to sort of put on
this celebrity hat and then the award
came and it all just works together you
know hand in hand the film does well
people recognize you you get nominations
so even through the whole process it was
just going by so fast and I didn't
really understand or had the knowledge
as to what I was supposed to do in this
celebrity world of like you know red
carpets and photographers so when I went
to the Independent Spirit Awards I
didn't know I had to be there early to
walk the red carpet I was just like it
said 730 but there was like the 630 red
carpet and it's like man I'm just not
good at this stuff and I wasn't and just
nervous you know because now you're
sitting at this big ballroom style tent
actually in santa monica and there's all
these really well-known actors but most
of them independent because you know the
independent cinema world wasn't as big
as it is now it was just sort of
creeping in sundance was more of a you
know novelty
back then then than it is now more
commercially so being in that setting
was very nerve-racking because they're
calling out these names and you know
you're coming up next and you're just
like I don't have a speech I don't know
what goes hey I just like I didn't
expect to win and I didn't win which was
cool because I was like look I got a
nice little gift bag and I got some free
food so I was I was content with all
that then you know other things came
along like I got this gap ad where they
plastered my face on a 14-story building
on Sunset Boulevard and it's all a bit
overwhelming because you are not bigger
than yourself and it's hard to to try
and stay humble and still you know
maintain this image of you that that's
bigger than you especially when you're
like 14 stories tall now you're like oh
my gosh so picky so it was difficult for
me i would say early on in my career
because i didn't know it so anyone who
comes into hollywood i definitely
recommend you know getting an agent
getting a manager and you know getting a
publicist especially if you have a film
that you believe is going to make it big
get a publicist they're awesome because
they really they really educate you on
that part of the world the business and
and really help you understand what you
need to do and what's important
then I did a little stint as an
assistant agent in Hollywood so I can
get a better understanding of how agents
work in this business and you learn a
lot you learn a lot you learn that say
seventy percent of actors only focus on
the show and not the business and I
think that's who I was before the
Independent Spirit Award and then after
I was much more knowledgeable of the
business side show business so that's
interesting can you break down what is
the show and then what is the business
part because I hear so many people that
I know I don't want to do that I'm gonna
once i get big and have people they'll
do it for me but what happens when
you're not at that level yet how do you
I think there's a resurgence or just a a
new wave of artists in this town where
they realize that you like I said
earlier you can't just be an actor you
have to be so many other things director
producer you know assistant agent
because you have to understand that this
is a business and most actors just come
here wanting to work but you have to go
through the business in order to get
that work that you want to do so so
badly and I've seen so many actors walk
away from and be like no I don't care
about the business or contracts or this
and that but it's so essential it's so
important and it's like the the yang to
your yang
you know it really is essential and now
for me I feel that I have a bigger
picture of not just as of the acting
world but of this business as a whole
and it makes me more respectable of all
the people who are involved in making a
project happen and from the casting
directors to the agents of you know how
hard they work and what they have to put
up with in their own realm you know and
publicists as well everybody has their
own situation or you know job tasks that
they have to pursue and and get done so
I think when you acknowledge that it's a
business and you educate yourself about
the business you have the ability to be
more successful and if you'll notice
that the actors who are extremely
successful are very very much aware even
I'm sure Daniel day-lewis is very much
aware of the business of his career
extremely and I think he he manages it
really well so it's important
you